día y noche durante las últimas dos
semanas los camioneros han paralizado a
la capital canadiense el llamado convoy
de la libertad de inicio para protestar
contra la obligatoriedad de la
vacunación impuesta a los transportistas
que querían atravesar la frontera entre
eeuu y canadá pero el movimiento ha
crecido y ahora condena las
restricciones por ccoo y 19 y al
gobierno de ellos sin trudeau el amor no
vote por él no le diga ni voto y sólo
quiero jesmond
justin bieber hosting si es esto quiero
que dejes el gobierno quiero que lo
dejes por completo y complete la
protesta ha ganado visibilidad global
con manifestaciones surgiendo en otras
partes del mundo en nueva zelanda
camiones y caravanas convergieron en
frente del parlamento el martes para
protestar contra las medidas sanitarias
y los mandatos de vacunas ordenados para
algunas profesiones
creo que la protesta canadiense inspiró
a muchos militantes a salir y tomar
acción porque si la gente se sienta y no
dice nada nadie va a escuchar nuestra
voz
el jueves la policía trató de dispersar
a la multitud 120 personas fueron
arrestadas un movimiento similar también
ha tomado fuerza en francia un convoy
partido de la ciudad de niza el
miércoles van hacia parís antes de
dirigirse a bruselas
dónde y apoyamos el convoy de la
libertad estamos muy contentos de ver lo
que pasó en canadá y ver lo que ahora
pasa en europa y en el mundo venimos a
apoyar a todos quienes van a partir para
defender nuestras libertades julio
libertad de cara a su llegada a la
capital francesa de la policía parisina
ha prohibido de las caravanas una
protesta se prevé para el viernes